what would you recommend for young
musicians and how to get
good what are the different paths a
person can take to understand it deeply
enough to create something
special I think first and foremost
understanding why you are playing music
if it's because you have something that
you're trying to express or that you're
just in love with expression itself with
art itself self those are great
reasons
um to to start this journey the why
should be I think the why is really
important because it's a jagged
lifestyle and there's a lot in it and so
if you don't have your purpose if you're
not centered in your purpose then all
that that Jagged lifestyle is probably
going to get to you Jagged it's Jag yeah
it's Jagged it's it's it's all over the
place it's uncertain it's one thing one
moment and a completely different thing
another moment you never know what's
going to happen and if you thrive on
variety which I love variety um then
it's it's
perfect but also every human being needs
a certain amount of certainty in
structure and so it's the certainty can
come from your inner knowing knowing
that you're doing exactly what you want
to be doing and knowing what your
purpose is in in doing it in this
expression otherwise you're just kind of
like a leaf blowing in the
wind like in the early days touring just
playing clubs seems like tough yeah it's
a lot yeah it's a lot of like the
physical labor aspect of it is really
hard playing on stage to to two people
or 2,000 or 20,000 that doesn't make a
difference I mean it makes a difference
to the ticket sales which informs how
what level of uh luxury you might have
on the road or not but other than that
it's just people there listening to
music the music doesn't
change does it make it tougher when it's
two people versus 200 no so even if
nobody recognizes whatever the thing
you're doing no because the the idea is
to be doing like having a great
conversation on
stage the audience can come and go yeah
I mean I I always like at like there's
certain points in shows where I I'm just
like I consciously I'm like oh yes
there's an audience over there cuz I'm
so like wrapped up in whatever's
happening on stage you forget yourself
well maybe I'm remembering myself oh wow
damn call back somehow feels like
one